[Musique]
voilà une jolie à 2,7 ya trois bien
nettoyer dit voir de sa va alors être
kilowatts mais n'oubliez pas de vote
dans tout un tas plâtre et le numéro
parce que thomas maurion pas possible
faute de place j'ai pas de classement
les galas geek and à l'eau larguée par
chu minutes dont il pas qu'il avait
changé de siège et progéria sera changé
ma vie on ne sème un sujet en avril
alors s'est produit un peu partout on
peut pas changer les sièges parce que je
sais plus ma maison
mais j'ai pas si georges marchais on
aurait leur faire faire un concours
jacques martin et pierre perret oui et
non ça les juges voient là et ça c'est
important
je suis acheté ce matin on va tout ce
que j'ai trouvé comme ça ben dis-donc
match et pas comme toi à moi j'achète
des petites bricoles j'achète de quinoa
petite actrice les meilleurs fusils ne
s'est pas vrai je suis du côté des
femmes aux fourneaux il ya que toi que
jamais donné mon métier rare de les voir
la seule femme serait par les chefs à
lyon
là
ouais
j'en fais une fois j'avais du meilleur
match race humaine donné un mois au fait
il est bien mais je veux avec ton père
c'est pour le promosport l'heure juste
et le meilleur mois
mais gare à pâté
ça peut passer
on part pour les contractuels dans ces
massacres
les champignons avant dessous
mais les champions mollahs l'échappement
voilà je me sois là ça la blague tout
cas ce qui
on a comme ça pour ça
c'est même pas pour les clients gaza
la salade pour les clients les fromages
pour les clients
voilà
je fais là s'est rebellé à voir
[Applaudissements]
bientôt je vous faire voir que pour
faire ce que shana recevoir 30 ans de
métier tous coupés régulier toi je fais
pareil pareillement mais je vais
doucement moi j'ai peur de me couper le
doigt par yapi rôle qu'il adore la
cuisine puis j'ai fait des aubergines
moi je voulais la mer qui fait très
chaud leur cuisine
j'ai l'habitude janvier d'accord mais
[Musique]